i'm just going to say we have tj
here from princeton and he's going to
talk about voltage and resource and
learning
thank you okay okay
okay hello everyone i'm chi-ching
actually thanks for inviting me to give
this tutorial simon's bootcamp
so today i'm going to talk about the
multi-generation enforcement learning i
hope you guys learned a lot about
reinforced learning this morning and
from dylan's talk
so yeah i'm going to build upon a little
bit on that and also
probably more on the what we have
learned in the past few days in game
theory and then we're going to go for
multigenerating postmodern
i'm from princeton and the slide is on
my home page it should be very easy to
find it on my homepage and also we kind
of we have a similar content so it's
already on the blog post which is
written by you and me
on the on this website
uh first i want to like thanks a lot of
the contributors uh the the contents
that present a lot of results are like
from my group also from these
contributors like this kind of knowledge
we gather together work together over
the past few years and they are you buy
from salesforce and chiang halio from
princeton and you are haa from princeton
and also attention youth from mit
first let's motivate it why we want to
study like the multi-gene reinforcement
learning
if we if we kind of consider back again
what are the really
biggest success over the past few years
like in reinforcement learning or in
like the field of ai you might come up
with like okay the game of gold and also
starcraft 2 and even like some texas
poker
where basically we our human already
built some
a and
some
some some intelligent agents which is
able to beat the world champion in on
those games which were thought to be
like super hard
if you will
consider a little bit more about all
those kind of games they actually has
two properties
one is uh they are kind of involved
multiple agents it's not like a single
agent it's not a single player playing
the game it's kind of you you need at
least two players it's kind of multigen
games so it definitely involves some
game theory
and the second part is not only a simple
game it's actually a game that involves
a sequence sequential decision making so
it requires you to make a sequence
decision and see the feedbacks of the
other players and then build on those
feedbacks and make the other decisions
so we can see that all those games kind
of consist of just two parts so we can
look at the theory of both of them
each of them the first one is we look at
the classical game theory classical game
theory uh i guess also um
also some of the topics of what you have
already heard in the past few days are
about uh normal form games or extensive
form games
normal form games are those games which
basically you can represent the entire
game reward as a matrix
so
all the players just play simultaneously
and then this game is done so there's no
sequential information or there's no
time series at all like involving these
non-form games
extensive form games is a little bit
better and actually extensive form games
is pretty good in like modeling those
poker games
where essentially they model the game as
a tree so each player take actions and
you follow the path of those actions and
go to leaks and you receive the rewards
however we notice one a little bit like
inefficient part about the extensive
form gaming so
it's kind of grow exponentially with
steps okay the size of trees were
exponentially with steps
so for a lot of the games we're playing
for example starcraft we're gonna play
this game for 20 minutes and each minute
we're gonna play probably 660 actions
so
the size of the game tree is going to
explode on the it's going to grow
exponential on the like length of the
horizon so this extensive 4pm is a
extensive form games is not very
efficient in representing those kind of
sequential games especially with a very
long horizon
on the other hand
we say one is about notation game the
other one is about sequential
decision making so there actually exists
a framework called like reinforcement
learning which just
basically entire entire field is like
building dealing with those sequential
decision making problems
so it has an agent it will it will
interact with the environment so agent
will feed the action to the environment
while environment will
feedback the states and rewards so that
there is a loop going on between the
agents and the environment its kind of
interaction
so the goal of the agency in
reinforcement learning is to try and
find the best policy within a fixed
environment okay so this is a actually
the goal of the single agent
reinforcement and all that algorithm is
designed based on the assumption the
environment is fixed
however we kind of realized in the very
beginning we introduced those examples
like the goal or
starcraft and all those games are
opponents are not fixed it's not we're
not playing against some fixed ai we're
competing with
other human players they can adapt they
can change their strategy over the
course like they can even change their
strategy during doing like the world
championship during the final so
it's not a good assumption to assume
they're fixed
and a single agent reinforcement seems
not directly applied there
so there we kind of come to the
multi-generation enforcement learning we
kind of know it involves both game
theory and reinforcement learning
but as we will argue today the age the
area is actually a lot more than just
simple combination of those two
so we say this field is actually a very
new field and it's much less developed
than the two classical fields like game
theory and reinforcement learning
and also the new field of motion
reinforcement has a lot of its own
unique challenges and opportunities we
will also see today
so the task today is we want to
establish a solid theoretical
foundations of multi-reinforcement
learning of course it's not going to be
that solid as a already established game
theory and reinforcement learning but we
want to start from the very basic and
what we can do from those basic settings
and to differentiate
the results or the material are going to
present today from the very classical
game theory
is about the
a lot of focus on this efficiency okay
so we will actually pay a lot of
attention on the sample efficiency and
the computational efficiency
the reason we care about those is in
modern reinforcement learning or more
than multi-reinforcement learning
actually those
efficiency matters a lot for example
when you want to train an
agents for playing gold and alphago zero
actu already trained on this google
cluster which has thousands of of
computers it's already trained on more
than like 10 to the seventh games okay
so it involves huge number of samples it
also the entire training is took more
than a month so basically you want to
train in
at school probably you can't do it just
because we don't have completion
efficient algorithm so far for those
kind of models
so that's why our theory not only
involves statistics but also involve
computations computer science so we want
to have both statistical efficiency and
conditional efficiency
okay
so i hope i already give you some good
advice to motivates you to
pay more attention to this
multi-generation enforcement learning i
guess uh
this is like a theory
workshop so i will not do too much about
other motivations we'll directly jump
into the theoretical frameworks
so i will to accept the basic
theoretical frameworks for multi-age and
reinforcing learning
i will cover the following
following parts
first one is about formulation and
objectives
so we know
normal form games and extensive form
games are no longer enough
so we will introduce a new model or
maybe not new model but it's just
different model which already exists for
a lot of years and what is the learning
objectives in those models
and then we will first talk about the
approach which is uh we said direct
combination of game existing game theory
and the simulation reinforcement
algorithms which is actually commonly
used in practice right now because this
is just some simple strategy which you
will first think of like
when you consider
these problems
and we will actually see why those
methods may not be very desirable and
and what is a problem with those methods
then we will like start from the very
beginning we will talk about the most
basic setting that is two player zero
sound markov games
and we will also focus on the basic
setting about a temporary setting and we
will see how we establish the solid
result for this kind of scenario
and then we will extend we'll go beyond
the zero sum setting to the multi-agent
general something
and we will see what's the difference
and how we deal with this difference
and finally we will also talk a little
bit about the topic if we have advanced
topics if we have times like including
function approximation i bet dylan
already talks a lot about this kind of
thing when we have a
like huge state space and how we deal
with
how we do this reinforcing learning we
need a lot of function approximation
techniques we will also talk a little
bit about the partial observability and
the kind of groups of the talk
any questions so far
i guess also this is like a boot camp so
the inspiratory bootcamp i'll try to
make everything simple and if you have
any questions feel free to interrupt me
at any time
so first about the formulations and
objectives
so we said we no longer the normal form
against an extensive form of beams are
no longer good for study
multi-reinforcement learning so the
model we're going to study is instead of
a markov vision process we're going to
study so-called markov games or in the
literature also called stochastic games
so this stochastic game is introduced in
sharply 1953
and it can be considered as an extension
of my composition process to multi-gene
scenario
i hope you already like a very familiar
remarkable process this morning so just
to be quick about all the notations
so here the
um for simplicity we first introduced
the two player zero sound version of
minecraft games and this mark of games
will consist of the following elements
that is states action
and the transition and the reward and
the horizon
first this curly ass is a set of states
and this kerdi ap are the set of actions
for the max player and mean player with
because we're playing like two player
zero sum games so assume one player is
max player the other player is a mini
player
and we all have we also have a
transition probability that is a
condition on the current states and the
action of the both player and we will
what is the probability distribution
we're going to transition to the next
state
and finally the reward because this is
zero something we can only specify just
one reward which is a reward for the max
player but also the loss for the mean
player we can think the reward for the
main player is the negative root word
for the next player okay reward also
depends on the states action but for
both players
and finally h is the horizon of the game
so we're considered episodic setting
similar the same as a what we had
introduced this morning so we assume the
game will end always ends at step h
so this introduced the elements of
marvel games so how we play markov games
this is the interaction protocol we
specify to play markup names
we can consider
for example we are playing a starcraft
which is
which we can model as a mark of games
environment always sample from some
sample some initial states that is where
kind of start from the beginning of the
game
then for each step is from one to h that
is like which step of how we play the
game
first both asians me and my opponents
will take some action simultaneously
that is i'm gonna click the mouse to
some place some place and my opponent
probably also click mouse to move some
units
and then both agents will receive their
own immediate reward
so this is like the both agent take
action simultaneously and then both
agents will receive their immediate
rewards
which max players like plus reward and
mean players minus reward then the
environment will based on the
current states and the two actions both
player takes and transition to the next
states that is h plus one
and uh
we will we will first say so what is a
reveal to the
um to the player in this case um
when we both take action simultaneously
the agent is able to observe the action
taken by the opponent
and also when we transition to the next
states the agent is able to observe the
states of the game
so that is in this talk we will mostly
focus on the fully observable tabular
amount of games in the very end if we
have time we will talk about some more
advanced things
okay
so what we mean by fully observable
tabular markov games
the fourier observable means um
we actually have joined actions and
states both are fully revealed to both
agents there isn't any like partial
observation of the ability and the
entire state is hidden the entire state
is observed by asians so for example
when i applied to starcraft 2 if if some
of you played soccer too you probably
know like there are some more frogs so
that you you are not able to
observe what your opponent is playing
and like when you play poker you're not
able to observe what your opponent's
card is
so for simplicity now we don't assume we
have partial visibility so we just
observe
everything
the second
thing is about temperature setting
temperature setting is assumed the
number of states and number of actions
are all finite and small
these are very basic settings you may
wonder okay this may not be applied to
practice
like very applicable to like the current
practice but we will argue this is
actually serve as a very very very
foundation for advanced setups in the
future so if we want to understand for
example the visual observation setting
or like the large state setting function
prototyping i think the very basic step
we always need to first understand what
is what we can do in a tabular scenario
and what we can do in the following
observation
and a few concepts similar to what we
have been talking about this morning
one is about the policy
uh i guess in march of in a single
scenario we must talk about the market
policy
that is uh let's without larger without
loss of generality we talk about the max
player so the the type of market policy
is the policy which only depends on the
current states so i observe what is
current states and i make decisions
based on the current states so it's a
map from current states to the
probability simplex of action so let's
assume we can we can play a stochastic
policy that is we can actually play a
distribution of algorithm in reality i
just sampled an action from this
distribution
and the ability to place randomized
action is very important in here because
in game we always need to play random
strategy to to be able to accomplish
much equilibrium
we will also talk about another class of
policy that is called general policy
okay by the name you'll see the general
policy may not be markup
so the biggest difference is this
class of general policy may not
necessarily only depend on the current
states
it can possibly also depends on the
entire history
so based on the mass formulation it is a
map not only from the current states but
also the state's action pair from the
entire history that is the action pair
of all the past steps
from the first step to h minus one steps
and map this entire history to some
distribution of actions
in a single region scenario we can
always like in mdp we can always say
without oxygen off of generality we can
consider markov card policies
but here we will see mark of things is
not always necessary in that case there
are some cases we have to talk about
general policies
and also we define this max policy in
this way and the policy for max pair in
this way we can also define the policy
for the main player by symmetry this is
pretty simple you just
change the distribution as probability
symbol x over a to probably it seems
of b
once we have definitional policies then
we can talk about the values
value is only defined on the drawing
policy that is i have to specify both
the policy
of the agents and also also the policy
of the opponents then we can talk about
the value
value is expected accumulation rewards
received by the max player if both
agents follow these joint policies
so the definition is basically i got a
summation of rewards from the very first
step to the very last step so this is
total rewards i'm going to receive when
i play the game
and if the boss player i'm going to take
expectation over pi because both players
gonna going to
play by the policy pack
and this is my value
any questions so far about the basic
formulation
this so players do uh do players know
about their opponent's policies
oh they they don't they only observe
opponents actions i see
that's a good question thanks
okay and uh we already should introduce
the the model of markup games we can
consider what like how expressive this
smart games is and we just note first
some special cases first one is the
normal form games
it's very simple we realize in our home
game this is a special case of markov
games just because we can make a mark of
games with just a single state without
any transition so we have only single
step then those markov beams will reduce
to the normal form games
and it is also uh
extensive form games is also a special
case of markov games
we can basically embed an extensive
program into a mark of games by
restrict the transition structure to
have two must be tree structure so that
is uh whatever the i start from the
different states i cannot end up with uh
with the same states so this is a
property for extensive form game but
it's not necessarily required in market
games in marvel games it's possible i
start with two different states and then
i take some actions i end up with the
same space in the next step which is
also the case for example for starcraft
for go for some different games okay
after we clear about the class of the
mark of games the formulations then the
next question we're going to consider is
what is the
solution we're trying to find
in a single unit in a single scenario in
a markov division process it's very easy
we just want to find the policy which
maximizes the cumulative rewards
however here it's become more
complicated
let's just consider what is the
for example the the problem of goal
like we want to develop a half a goal um
so what is the ultimate
objective we want to achieve for
designing this like a very good
moderation reinforcement learning
algorithm
do we want to beat the world champion
by a large margin
is this policy good or do we want to
beat all the players by a large margin
we clearly know the second second second
objective probably just not not possible
because we can just always play that
against ourselves and it's not we cannot
win by analyzing
and the first objective win the world
champion and by a large margin
so this is a what is a concept of the
best response so best response is so is
a is it's also we also have concept of
best response in normal home games so
it's a similar concept in the markup
means so best response is a policy which
exploits best exploits opponent's policy
so in our notation of markov games we
have a value that is depends on the
policy of the max player and also the
mean player that is pi y and the pi 2 so
the best response of the pi 2 the the
policy of the mean player is just the
policy so which maximize the value of
this b pylon python
so we know this a special case of markov
game is a is like a normal form game
where you know the best response of
you know rock paper scissors is like
very easily understandable it's like a
best response of rockets uh paper best
response of paper is scissors and in
this in a complicated game like
starcraft we also have like similar
concepts like a rocket paper scissor for
example there might be three strategies
in the very beginning you can do some
normal opening you can do some fast
expansion you can also do some fast
attack
and these three strategies like rock
paper scissors they connect the pc
shutter in a loop type fashion
however we know there are some drawbacks
about the batch response best response
is very good against a fixed opponent
for example if our goal is really just
want to beat like some fixed world
champion like just just just one single
person then this way is very good we
just find a very good policy that
exploits the weakness of that opponent
but however the best response may not be
very good against other players
like we already we all know in rock
paper scissors the best response of the
rock is just a paper but it's not very
good against caesar
so now we turn to another concept that
called nash could do i guess is very
familiar for the
other audience in this in this bootcamp
nash equilibrium is a it's like a very
famous concept in normal form games
in mark of games we can also define ash
equilibrium as a the same way as normal
form claims which is just no player has
incentive to deviate from their current
policy
for example here for any
we say pi 1 star pi 2 star is a nash
equilibrium
if
if if when you fix python star fix the
policy of the mean player it already
achieved the maximum for the max player
okay so the value will be greater than
the value of
pi one pi two star for any pi one
at the same time when you fix pi 1 star
the policy of the max player you'd also
achieve the minimum value for the second
player for the main player so it will be
less than the value of
the pi lines dot pi
2. all know in the normal form games
there's one very famous theorem called a
mir-mac theorem
so in reality for zero player for two
players there are some microphones the
mini maximum still holds
we have the minimum over pi one max over
pi two mean max over strategies
the value is equal to the the maximum
value is equal to the mean max value
however we we notice several difference
the first one is uh in the normal form
games you require
this to be mixed strategy
here it's sufficient we just make it to
be a single policy it's okay because
policy we already make a random policy
so policy in some sense is uh is like
similar to mixed strategy
on the other hand we also
also want to comment a little bit this
theorem is actually not due to von
neumanns directly due to honolulu's
minimal theorem
the reason is this structure is much
more complicated than the normal
formations while neumann's minimax
theorem kind of says for any function
which is convex concave you have minimax
theorem called
however you can prove for mark of games
this
v pi 1 pi 2 this value function is a
function of both policy but it is not a
convex concave function of type 1 and
python that is fixed one pi 2 is not
complete commax on pi y and the fixed
down pi one is not concave on pi two
however this min max theorem is still
true
because you can basically prove it by
dynamic programming and e for each state
and step you can say minimax volumes
minimum maximum true and then you can do
the dynamic programming and you see it
for the entire markup gain this means
maximum still holds
so the good thing about this minimax
theorem is this also gives another
interpretation of this nash equilibrium
why we want to learn nash equilibrium in
markov games
because nash equilibrium is now
a policy which is optimal when we always
facing against best response
okay so
basically here there's no difference
between stack of equilibrium and the
nash equilibrium in our two-player
zero-sum games
and it is an optimal strategy in a
minimax sense it's also optimal in a
maximum sense
like for example for a rock paper
scissor
it's optimal because uh no matter what
my opponent plays
i will never lose so my opponent will
never going to exploit me so the
strategy we're going to find is not
going to beat anybody by a large margin
we may not be able to win anyone by
large margin but a strategy we're going
to find is going to guarantee nobody
going to beat us
similar to this normal form game this is
a the final goal we're gonna find
so our objective in a two player zero
sound form and zero sum games is going
to find a epsilon approximately nash
equilibrium which we know as a pi 1 hat
python hat
our objective is we want to find this
object a nash equilibrium using a small
number of samples which which has a very
mild dependency on the states and
actions s a1 a2 and epsilon nh
so it should show the a b and basically
the number of actions of both players
and in terms of mathematical definitions
so this requires the epsilon approximate
nash equilibrium basically this is the
duality gap which is similar to a new
normal form of grains is less than
epsilon
we know for the exact nash equilibrium
this gap is equal to zero
so for approximately equilibrium we
allow this to be have some excellent
tolerance
okay
any questions so far about all
setups what is objective we're trying to
find
so
i guess so far it seems like everything
is uh
similar to normal form games and
we just have different notations and
maybe with slightly different proof but
all the structures
remain similar
but i will name a few challenges which
uh which makes the algorithm we're going
to design fairly different from this
classical algorithm for non-homogeneous
the first one is the large size of the
positive space okay so marvel policy is
defined as
even considered micro policy in the
terrorist setting is defined as we have
we need to choose a probability
distribution over access for all states
at every steps
so the different the number of possible
market policies is one over epsilon to
the hsa if you consider covering number
and if you just naively treat this
markov games as a like a super large
normal form game then your pure action
the action you're gonna take is gonna
have this amount of size
so basically any algorithm you're gonna
use for normal phone games directly
applied on markup games will incur a
huge amount of sample capacity or like
computational maxi which is not feasible
in practice
and the second interesting part is uh
nash equilibrium we can prove measure
equilibrium strategy is always smart
problem
it is a micro policy however the best
response may not be the micro policy
this will also reduce and introduce a
lot of complications
because
it may not be very easy to find best
response in this scenario
and finally
also because of what we have in the
second part
we talk a lot this week about solving
games by no regret learning strategy
however one very big difference of
markov pin from a standard normal
convenience markov games do not allow
any efficient no no regret out learning
algorithms
this is proved in our paper with
by ebay and tension use in 2020.
so basically what we are saying is uh if
you if you're able to do no regret
learning for microgreens you're going to
solve like learning parity with noise in
polynomial times so it's a combination
of harness results the the major reason
there is uh
like uh by doing no regret learning
you're gonna need to do finding best
response of your opponents
and your although the game is mark of
games so the game has markup structure
your opponents need not to play markups
policy so they can play some complicated
like time dependent policies the first
step is going to depends on the not step
so in those scenarios
learning the best response is kind of
like very difficult like you need to
infer some like a long time correlation
which uh which is going to increase some
time which is exponential image
it's all because this is like a
sequential feature we have like h steps
and we want to avoid this exponential
depends on h so a lot of things becomes
different
okay
so
any question about until now this
basically concludes about the
formulations and i kind of briefly
talked about the challenges later on we
will talk more detail in detail about
what is specific challenges and how we
adjust this so i have two questions one
is the epsilon that you're showing the
large size of policy space
this is one over epsilon and this this
epsilon refers to what
oh it's just like a i want to do an
epsilon cover over the microphones
like because the microphones because the
policy is like you map to the
probability simplex right you kind of
you take up random action which
corresponding to choose a proper
distribution of action
and so this is the discretization over
this space of actions right right
uh and then
in the bottom you have alpha
what is this alpha
oh this is just saying no regret i
define no regret learning in terms of
i'm going to compete with the best best
policy in inside and i'm going to
achieve some regrets which is the sub
linear which is standard definition
right so
you can achieve it but there is no good
algorithm or you cannot even achieve it
uh you can achieve it but it's not
efficient
in terms of age
in terms of page okay so so
this is what i mean by efficient no
regard learning so what i'm saying we
cannot achieve it because we cannot
achieve politics
we will have some exponential issue
so
here what i mean is like in order to
achieve this no regular learning here we
need some computational inefficient
algorithm which is a skill explanation
edge
this is why
but later we should actually we can talk
about some strength science and version
of this result
so one question i had and there's also
one question on the chat
so
i guess many like even contextual
bandits like if you don't make some
oracle assumptions things will be super
hard
for is this setting so is there some
oracle impossibility result here like
even if you have some best response
oracle
uh you
you can't get no regret learning like is
like if i give you some oracle heuristic
could you achieve no regret i guess the
hardness here actually exactly lies in
the best response is hard
just because i said the best response
may not be market policy so it's
possible your opponent is is always
pretty much opposite but because he's
like playing key rounds of market policy
so the mixture of them is no longer
markov positive and you are competing
with the best response of a non-market
policy center you're competing with the
best result forms of a mixture of
monetary policy which is like a history
dependent policy and it's very difficult
to compete
asking is what if you restrict your
opponent to mark of strategies
even if you'll restrict your appointment
to my heart strategy no right no rather
than steal heart
basically the the
the reason i said it is like a auto
opponent is like a can play markup
policy at every iteration but when you
have two rounds of markup policy your
opponent is effectively playing a
mixture of minor policy which is not
markup
thanks
[Music]
so let's continue
so we will first talk about that
okay go ahead
um sorry i i didn't understand why the
nash equilibrium policies markov
can you explain this
we will talk about this later later but
basically you become proof with the
biodynamic providing we haven't come to
that so far but this is like just some
challenge which we i want to spice you
to
be interested in this problem
we'll come to some more details later
later on
thank you for the questions
first we will talk about some simple
stuff about some direct
combination of what existing algorithm
for game theory and what we have for
reinforcement singulation reinforcement
learning algorithm
so this approach this direct combination
is a all relies on like a very key
observation that is uh if we're going to
fix opponents if my opponent is fixed
then computing the best response is kind
of like a single asian reinforcement
learning problem like
because my opponent effects then
opponents across the environment is just
big environment i can view it as a
single environment and i can use
single-engine reinforcement to do it
so the style of this algorithm kind of
like uh
needs to it's like hybrid of the two
algorithm the first one is the standard
nash finding algorithm for normal formal
games
um a very important part is this not
finding algorithms must be this our
best response oracle-based national
planning algorithms because eventually
we want to reduce to only final invest
response
and then we're solving the best response
steps we just use whatever single engine
reinforcement in our business
so the commonly used like those uh nash
binding algorithms in the multi-gene
reinforcement setting is like cell play
fictitious play and double oracle they
also psro which is like some extension
of double oracle
for for simplicity here we just called
which is the double our code
and a single agent algorithm
reinforcement you can use any algorithm
didn't introduce this morning like value
iteration q learning and deep q network
which is a deep learning version of q
learning and also some policy
optimization like a proximal process
optimizing ppo prpo a lot of them
this actually is a fairly common
strategy using practice and if you
if you have ever read like alpha star
which is the like technical notes uh or
like the paper and deep mind posts on
like how they struck how what what are
their strategies in solving like finding
the
i mean like to train their agents for
starcraft 2 it's kind of vaguely
following this uh high level framework
following this strategy
let's first talk about the um this uh
like match finding algorithm with the
best response overcome
first of all in cell phone
cell play is an extremely simple
algorithm
some first thing you can think of
basically
we have two players the first led player
first find the last response of the
second player and then the second player
again find the best response of the
first player and then first player find
the best with zero seven you kind of are
changing between those two
well clearly i know this this is not a
very good strategy
because in rock paper scissors we kind
of like even in the normal form games
if this algorithm were just looping
around like a rock paper scissors those
are like single strategy forever
this do not converge to nash equilibrium
even in a very basic non-form games
and second we also realized averaging
would not help basically because uh
um although kind of you know what paper
scissors are kind of like looking around
and one third one that i want to
probably doing averaging is the right
thing but what we can do is we can just
slightly change the reward
matrix for the rock paper scissors games
for example if you win with rock you
probably won't get a reward while you
get row 0.9
this is sufficient to shift the nash
equilibrium to to be deviating from like
a one third or 100 uniform distribution
for rock paper scissors but if you play
cell play like you just do this self
play algorithm you would still converge
to the uniform distribution to average
so averaging is not enough to fix this
problem so this problem this algorithm
just not very
good the second one is uh
there's one one more question yes go
ahead
all right this may be a dumb question
but i thought we didn't have access to
the other players policy
oh uh so we we kind of act with
um okay in the in the interaction
protocol we don't have access to the
other pairs or act and positive this is
uh like when we play the game
but uh but there uh what we talk about
is like training process so you know
okay what i'm saying is in a test
process you don't have access to the
opponent's policy but in a training
process you it's possible like you do
some
you do something like a
cell plate training okay that's outplay
is different from this cyclic so
basically when we when for example when
we train goal or when we train for
starcraft we can definitely control
both agents and let them learn learn
together so in this way we can reveal
the policies is
okay so basically my answer is like in a
training process and you you you can you
can communicate about other policies you
can do whatever the way like two player
can even
collaborate to like learn and match your
film together
actually now now i'm more confused
so
we have not talked about training
testing nothing right so
what is the model you're working on i
mean
specifically you said that we don't
assume anything about the opponent
there was nothing about test or
training okay so
the interaction model is like this
and uh in a okay so there are two parts
the first part is the training parts
okay let me clarify about genuine tests
in the training parts
we're going to able to like basically
two-pair
collaborates and they can they can do
whatever and they
they can communicate on all the
information they just need to interact
with the product or interact with the
environment with this protocol but they
can talk about anything that they want
all the information they have share all
the information they have but what i
mean by tests is like eventually you
find that a nash equilibrium and the
so for example i i train myself by
starcraft for like a month and
eventually i come up with a policy and
but eventually i'm gonna test that is
i'm gonna play with some world champion
or i'm gonna play with some other
opponents and when in this phase when i
play against other opponents i'm not
gonna observe what is policy of the
opponents
um
when you say training you basically mean
just the computation of the equilibrium
right it's like a centralized
decentralized algorithm that computes
the equilibrium can do whatever with
both policies and then eventually the
two players are going to play based on
those policies but when you compute the
equilibrium as a centralized algorithm
in your computer you can
uh look at what are you what is your
current guess for players to policy and
design a policy for player one and so on
so forth thing to iterate until you find
an equilibrium and how they play
it so basically during training you
assume that you know the policy of both
players
during training basically means just
computing the equilibrium like the
argument computes the equilibrium of
this markovian game
when they play the game
they're going to play based on these
policies
that uh obey this interaction
well the only thing for us is there's a
difference between computing the
equilibrium when you
know like the probabilities and the
rewards and so forth and computing the
equilibrium when you only see like
trajectories okay yeah that's uh that's
a valid yeah yeah we'll also talk about
that later but then i think so far we
haven't talked about anything about
unknown or stochastic or right so that's
why i was saying that at this point it's
more like a computation like someone
gives you a
a transition mod you know like a a world
and you're trying to calculate an
equilibrium
right and and i will just say a little
bit more about the uh the well when we
even when we talk about the like the
case we we observe only samples and we
also have like training and the test
phase like training like
when we observe the samples we kind of
we also want to just find the natural
equilibrium but based on the samples and
in those scenarios and also communities
i think the the training testing maybe
makes more sense as a keyword for the
sample based uh situation yeah but i
think it's it's you're right i think
it's probably the field also terminology
this is like a centralized algorithm but
we could also have decentralized
algorithm motion like players don't
commute even even in a training phase
and we will actually also come to the
algorithm like that
later in this instant
[Music]
a very good question
can i can i add something to this
discussion um
so here my understanding is that you're
basically computing equilibria right but
if i think about the alphago example the
idea is
it's not even sure that if i want to
beat uh you know professional i really
want to use the nash equilibrium
strategy i want to use a strategy that
does well against whatever i think it's
you know against maybe a variety of
strategies if i think of course that my
rival is not gonna play nash right
right so i think this is like a go back
to the very beginning like about a
solution concept so what you talk about
is you want to find a
probably best response or some some
supervisors around to a class of policy
but you don't want to find nash
equipment exactly i guess a good
algorithm in this case would be an
algorithm that sort of figures out what
policy marvel is using and best response
to that
i'm assuming that myrava's policy is
fixed right
so there are two parts one is uh like
there are two objectives obviously one
is about natural equilibrium which is
like defend against the
like uh
optimal player and the other one you
said is that you want to exploit some
suboptimal play of the opponents i think
that one is more related to no learning
and which is a very difficult amount of
games
maybe you cannot exploit very well but
but it's a different concepts and
which is not what i'm talking about
right now
but it is a very important thing
okay those are all very good discussions
and thanks for listening
okay so after cellplay we talk about
fixation play fictitious play is similar
to self-play but instead of just you're
gonna find the best response of
the immediate policy of your opponents
you first do an average policy of your
opponents and then you'll find a
response to that to be
okay so the for the max player is going
to find the best response of the average
policy of the of the main player and
then mean player is going to find the
best response of the average policy of
the max player okay so this is a
so-called fictitious play
when you inspect your fraction play on
rock paper scissors
it seems like it's making more sense at
least making more sense than itself
and in fact there are some asymptotic
conversions guaranteed about the display
which is by robinson 1951.
it says participate indeed will converge
to nash equilibrium which is uh also
heavily quoted by a lot of practitioners
which justify why they want to use
participatory for example to when they
train some multi-university problems
on the other hand at the theorists we
will
of course not only have we were not very
happy about only convergence we will ask
that next question how fast
how many iterations we need for this
particular to find large equilibrium
so if we inspect the proof of the
robinson 1951 it actually says it
requires something one of its own to the
omega a iteration a is like the number
of actions in normal form games
to find its own nash equilibrium which
is exponential in the number of actions
this clearly doesn't sound very good
so
karting conjecture in 1959
whether this this may not be just
artifact of the analysis maybe the
future is actually doing better so
whether this can really can be improved
with some one or excellent square to
find epsilon optimal nash
so
because in also in the audience he kinda
in 2014 he refilled this conduction and
he basically shows this uh one two over
epsilon two omega is kind of real in
some worst case scenario which basically
factor supply is not guaranteed to
to convert fast even in the normal home
games not mentioned about markup games
this we passed
finally we talked about double our code
so clearly there is something better we
can do that fixtures play fictitious
play basically just compute the best
response of the uniform weight of your
opponents
and what if i'm allowed to do something
like a more sophisticated weighted
average of the opponent's strategy
so one way to do weighted averages by
inspecting the reward matrix of the
subgame
so this sub game is a is consisted of
the other rewards that is uh
that is each row is uh each row is the
is a policy of the max player played in
the past and each column is a is a
policy of the main player play in the
past and the entry is basically the
value of playing back the game
so this is a like a sub uh reward matrix
for the sub game where you can only play
those policies that has already been
played by the max player and the mean
player
so what you can do is you first find the
nash equilibrium of this sub
of this sub gain
and then you use this nash equilibrium
which is a mixed strategy and you use
this nash equilibrium as mixing
mixing policy for your
um
to like compose your opponent's policy
and you'll find the best response of
that
this is a double oracle algorithm
so what is the theory of double oracle
algorithms um i want to talk about our
algorithm here is just to represent a a
general approach where you kind of do
this the weighted average of the of your
opponent's policy
but uh but not necessarily finding notch
it can be some other stuff but funny
knowledge is one of the good ways we can
do this
and there are in fact some conversions
guaranteed about nash double oracle
algorithm which says it can find natural
equilibrium in normal form games with
all a actions
with a actions in order a iterations
this looks better than fictitious play
however if we inspect why this guarantee
is true it's basically because
every time
if you guarantee uh
in a normal form game there are two
scenarios
one is like you compute the best
response you compute some new action
which has not been like played before
then you're kind of adding that action
to your to again some game matrix
or if you
don't have any new actions your best
response is your old actions then you
already should not equip them
so if you in the worst case if you
haven't see
if in every iteration you encounter a
new action then in a iterations your
matrix mk is going to be the entire game
matrix for normal form game so that's
why you're always going to ends in all a
iterations
see there's a question clarification
value depends on the states
uh
yes so i haven't talked about
so here what i'm saying the value here
is just
if always start from the very beginning
i definitely but but you're right like
uh for markup policies and you can also
define the value if you start from some
intermediate step that would depend on
us here i don't have any s dependence
just says that entire
values like the entire rewards all the
communicable rewards
start from the back of the player
beginning with the initial distribution
initial state sample financial issues
and uh
also if on the other hand if we
directly convert a minecraft game into a
normal form of games we see like uh the
action is kind of equivalent to a policy
markov game which we already said we
have like one episode
to the hsa prime and mark of games where
this a prime is number of action in
markovian which is the size of positive
and positive space it's exponentially
large in each snare
so
doing this is not a very efficient way
to solve the markup games
so we just summarized some drawbacks of
this direct combination approach
um one is this algorithm is those linear
algorithms trying to design based on
some black box usage of single legion
reinforcement learning and normal form
games which doesn't exploit too much
about the structure of markov games so
basically they still treat this game as
a normal home games just with
complicated actions
and the second we already said
converting this markov game into normal
form games would give us a huge number
of
action pure strategy which is like uh
very inefficient for all existing
algorithms to work
and then finally there's another factor
i haven't talked about which is a
finding best response
may not be
an easy singularity reinforcement
problem as i as we think
the reason is come back to the again we
talk about the the possibility of
opponent is playing non-markup
policy when opponent is playing market
policy of course in the video when like
for example when main players play
market policy in the view of mark
interview of the max player because the
environmental transition is marked off
and opponents pay microprocessor
the in the eyes of max player it's just
he just feels like he's playing my
complication process so that's why we're
playing single agent algorithm
but when your opponent is playing normal
program policy then
even in the eye of max player you can
you can see the structure and the the
game is no longer
reduced to a markov vision process there
actually some correlation between like
the first step and third step even
conditional states of the second step
and the reason we talk about
non-markovian policy is because if you
go back to see all the algorithms like
double oracle and also fictitious play
they always play some like uh some mixed
strategy of of the of this of the policy
they played earlier which is a mixed
strategy of the market policy which is
non-article
so that's why in those games it's
necessary to study this uh
this scenario when the opponent is
playing normal policy and you are no
longer serving mdp so in theory
like v learning a lot of i'm sorry like
q learning and variation those kind of
basic algorithms should not work their
theoretical guarantees should not
directly apply here
just a clarification about these
non-markovian policies can i redefine
the state space i mean if i remember
your definition the non-markovian policy
was depending on the end history entire
history
but can't i have that the state
summarizes the entire history so if i
redefine the state economy
you can but it's inefficient
so
if you define the space as an entire
history then your number of states is
something exponential in h okay which is
something you don't want
i guess uh i will stop here for the
first hour
and
if you have any questions feel free to
ask and then we kind of we finish the
other basic setup and talk about some
nice approach in the next tutorial in
next hour we will talk more about it
okay we we now know a setup for like not
very good solutions so what is a good
solution like how we're gonna solve
these problems
uh any questions
[Music]
uh sorry i might have missed this uh but
um
can you explain which uh games does this
model uh
model well
model one yeah with like which types of
games
uh i think it's uh okay so first is for
all sequential games
and uh i think the biggest difference of
this game an extensive form game is this
allows the states to be shared like to
allow the transition to have a graph
structure
um
so so basically you
start from two states you might end up
with the same states in the next step so
i think like starcraft or a lot
starcraft with some partial
observability but if you'll say like if
there's no obvious patch of
observability uh i could or like entire
games with poop player i think they all
like following the category of marvel
games
um sorry i guess i'm just asking because
um it seems like from one state we can
only move to one single other state
now we can move to a lot of different
states uh it's a transition distribution
it's the same as a markov division
process so from a single state
and some fixed action you'll have a
transition distribution over next days
that is you can possibly transition to
all states but with just with some fixed
distribution
it's specified by this children's
is that a question
thank you chi thanks and we'll be back
in half an hour thank you
oh